what's going on guys this is Rob and
Marvel has changed the origin of Night
Crawler and it's the Talk of the Town
and people who don't know anything about
Marvel Comics are pissed off about it so
the way this whole thing basically opens
up and we'll get to the origin here in a
second but the way it opens up is in
effect Mystique has kind of like
survived the whole attack on kcoa and
everything but she's just sort of popped
in and out of the X-Men Comics just
babbling on and screaming about where
her baby is and nobody really knows for
sure right but Nightcrawler ends up
showing up here and that's where this
conversation takes place we'll talk
about why it is it seems like her mind's
broken because that becomes a very
important part of this as time goes on
but the long and short of this is that
she runs over the initial origin that we
were all for the most part aware of when
it came to Nightcrawler and it's
actually Marvel tapping into two
different Origins the first one is X-Men
unlimited from 1994 and the other one is
Uncanny X-Men 428 in 200 whatever it was
written by Chuck Austin and the whole
thing about this is that in those origin
stories the only thing we knew from the
old X-Men unlimited comic in the 9s is
that Nightcrawler was the son of
Mystique and like that was it right
there was just a guy who was there that
she had basically gotten Knocked Up by
and then he was born and then he was
thrown off a bridge because she panicked
and like that was it in that story
Mystique kind of filled it in by saying
like he was the son of like a wealthy uh
baren more or less or like a wealthy man
but like that's really all it was in
Uncanny X-Men for 28 that expanded on
that original story vastly and it
introduced like Christian Wagner and the
idea is that Mystique herself was
operating as a woman named Rachel Wagner
the wife of Christian but Christian
himself simply couldn't have kids and
the result of this is that when you had
Mystique who came across a zazil and a
zazil was of course this kind of like
demonic entity that looks almost exactly
like Nightcrawler just different colored
skin that he had essentially gotten
there knocked up but this was done more
out of the fact that she was kind of
swindled with him right like she was
really legitimately in love with this
guy but as soon as he found out she was
pregnant with his child he bailed
because his goal was to just spread his
seed across as many women as he possibly
could and then take off on him as soon
as the deed was done and so in response
to that and with her husband basically
laying with her and kind of putting two
and two together right saying like you
know we had the doctors do a test and
the doctors r
you can have children but for whatever
reason I can't get you pregnant
obviously the problem's me but then now
you're suddenly pregnant at the same
time that a zazil takes off everybody's
talking everybody believes that you
slept with a zazil we should do some
kind of fraternity test she immediately
killed her husband and then from there
she just kind of masqueraded as both the
husband and the wife at different points
in time what this does at least this new
origin is it comes back and it changes
everything and what it really reveals
here is the fact that Nightcrawler is
the child of Irene Adler also known as
Destiny and Mystique which is kind of an
interesting thing because in the story
itself Nightcrawler kind of asked the
question like how in the world can the
two of you procreate you're both women
and she and her response is like don't
be dumb right like do you really believe
that when I take on the form of a person
that it's surface level and there's
actually an argument for this right in
Marvel Comics there's a character named
copycat Vanessa Carlile she actually has
the ability to not only take on the
physical appearance of other people but
actually copier Powers so it is a bit of
an adjustment to the historical powers
of Mystique and the sense that she
doesn't just take on someone's physical
form she modifies herself all the way
down to the genetic level and so what
she reveals here is that when her and
Irene Adler when her and Destiny first
met they of course fell in love but the
issue is that having a love affair
between two women at that point in time
was highly forbidden and so in order to
operate under the radar what they done
is they had at least my had brought
Destiny on is what was in effect a maid
now this is where things start to shift
and this is where things get different
that a zazil did take notice of Mystique
and he was very much enamored by
mystique and where he initially intended
to procreate with her and there was a
kind of affair going on there as soon as
you had Irene Adler who told Mystique
like I want to have I want us to have
like a family Mystique immediately ended
the relationship with a zazil seemingly
before she ever got pregnant and then in
turn Mystique got destiny pregnant now
here's the kicker about this right and
this is why a lot of those YouTube
channels that are complaining about this
have no idea what they're talking about
so one of the things to know is that
this was always the plan of Chris
Claremont and in fact this was laid out
in an interview that was not really done
by Claremont but was done by Scott loell
which was done by way of really a blog
post more than anything else where he
revealed that the original intention of
Chris Claremont was for the father of
Nightcrawler to actually be night
nightmare but that was shut down by
Marvel it was actually shut down by
Roger Stern because he didn't like the
idea of mutants being secretly related
to one another which seems to fly in the
face of everything dealing with
Quicksilver and skullet witch but the
bigger Point here is that in this
interview that Scott loell did from back
in 2011 he actually revealed that
Claremont had intended for mystique and
Destiny to have a kid together but
Marvel put the kabash on it because at
that point in time especially under
everything going on with Jim shooter and
even Tom DeFalco that there was no way
Marvel was going to allow uh Chris
Claremont to publicly reveal that
mystique and destiny were in a romantic
relationship let alone allow them to
have a child together so that origin was
put on the back burner and that's what
led to the X-Men unlimited origin in
1994 and then the expansion in Uncanny
X-Men for 28 and just for years it was
just the way that it was so that's
what's kind of cool about this right is
people are kind of like you know I wish
Marvel would go back to the days of
Chris claremon right this origin is
stupid okay well this is Chris
claremont's original origin so which one
is it guys but the thing about this is
that once this is revealed right once
night crawler learns about this you got
to get the rest of this story and the
reason for this being that in this
instance when the father or really like
Christian Wagner himself walks in on
what he believes to be his wife Rachel
and the maid that there is an effect A
Love Affair going on here due to like
just Society at that point in time would
have been killed they would have
literally been killed because that kind
of thing was like a big no no on a
societal level and so he even decides
and goes so far as to like call on
strumpets right like like safe as
perverts right he's like I'll have you
whipped and rolled in the gutter where
you belong and so in response like
Mystique kills him right off the bat
like she immediately kills this guy and
so that's one of the big differences
here the death of Christian Wagner is
not predicated on the idea that he kind
of put two and two together and realize
that like Mystique had an affair with
aasil and that he's not the biological
father and that it would really just
kind of destroy any credibility that he
has among the people around him instead
is predicated on the fact that he caught
Mystique with her girl and so in
response to that they just kind of leave
this guy right they literally just
execute him and like get rid of the body
and that's it the kicker about all this
is that once Irene gives birth to
Nightcrawler because of his physical
form he's considered this kind of
monstrous creature a demon is really
what Society at that point in time sees
him as and so what ends up happening
here is that instead of her doing what
she did and the original origin this is
especially an issue when like the doctor
and the nurse come in and they see like
mystique and Destiny together and
realize this child is like the some kind
of monstrous byproduct of A Love Affair
from their perspective that in turn like
she races off because they know the
town's people are coming for them the
town's people are going to kill them all
and so she basically puts night crawler
to safety right literally sits him under
a tree and then goes back for Destiny
but when she gets there Destiny's gone
when she gets back to where the baby is
Nightcrawler is gone and so seemingly
Destiny had escaped grabbed Nightcrawler
and left and so what this does is it
kind of fast tracks a little bit right
it jumps forward to what was in effect a
whole kind of conversation and so on
between uh Destiny and Mystique and what
Destiny revealed is that because of the
nature of a zazil and because of the
fact that she had had this Vision that
aasil was going to seemingly conquer
everything right like just by way of the
fact that he's demonic and Immortal and
Marvel's vastly overestimating his
powers um that there needed to be the
illusion that effectively Mystique was
pregnant with the baby of a zazil hence
the reason why it was Irene Adler
Destiny who told Mystique pretend like
you're pregnant right you can just kind
of go forward and do your thing and it
looks like you and Christian are going
to have a child together a zazil will
believe that he got you pregnant he'll
put his plans to conquer the Earth on
hold and that kind of thing and like
that'll basically be it and then in turn
you and I could have our baby in secret
and live our life the issue here is that
this caused irreparable damage between
the two of them right it basically
almost destroyed their relationship but
the love between them was strong enough
that they sought out some alternative
way to solve this problem so they met up
with Charles Xavier and what Xavier
agreed to do was in effect quote unquote
wipe their memories of everything that
had gone on or at least modify their
Memories the problem with this and what
Xavier literally told them to is he said
I shall of course Purge this whole
conversation from my own mind it's a
private matter you may find that you
have the lingering sense of a favor ODed
that seems fair right and so he says but
miss darkholm right talking to Mystique
I must warn you I've observed that where
memories have been perforated rather
than removed the mind will weave its own
stories around the imperfections callous
choices false affections you may find
the version you remember even uglier
than the truth and so that's kind of
like scci sper the guy who's writing the
story that's his way and really Marvel's
way of kind of coming along and saying
that's why Mystique remembers things
differently than the way they actually
were but the reason why it's all
flooding back here is because at the
beginning of fall of X when orcus forced
Xavier to send all these different
mutant through the portal that In This
Moment The False memories that were
modified and adjusted by Xavier were
wiped away and they simply revealed the
truth and that this is the truth that
Mystique was left with her mind was
trying to kind of compare and trying to
create some kind of reality or
understand what was going on between
these two things but that's effectively
the new origin right so it is what Chris
claremon originally wanted to do that
Marvel wouldn't let him do because of
the fact that it just was considered to
be a no no type thing from way back when
and that in turn now Marvel's doing it
because Society is generally more
acceptable so it's a cool thing let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section and I will catch you
all later peace